we're going to shift gears now to tell
you about the world's largest and most
powerful rocket which exploded yesterday
just a few minutes into its maiden
voyage NASA of course is counting on
that rocket made by SpaceX to carry
astronauts to the moon's surface and
potentially eventually Mars fortunately
no one was on board it was a test flight
and the FAA is now investigating as Mark
Strassman shows us SpaceX is still
considering this test flight a success
Starship the world's most powerful
rocket blasted off from South Texas for
what was supposed to be a 90-minute
flight around the globe or flying at
twice the thrust of the same time
but by 90 seconds into flight five of
its 33 engines had quit then 24 miles
over the Gulf of Mexico the rocket began
tumbling out of the sky we should have
had Separation by now obviously this is
uh does not appear to be a nominal
situation with a rocket veering off
course it activated its own
self-destruct system
total flight time four minutes from
Starship Mission Control SpaceX founder
Elon Musk tweeted congratulations to his
team learned a lot for next test launch
in a few months this was a very classic
Successful Failure this is the SpaceX
way former NASA astronaut Garrett
riesman now a SpaceX consultant nobody
got hurt today the rocket went kablooey
that's the technical term by the way
it's good Bluey but there are many more
waiting in the wings what do they
accomplish today so today we found out
what the weakest links are in the design
and they're going to fly again hopefully
within just a month or two and then
we'll find the next weakest link until
we find all of them 400 feet tall
Starship Towers over every other rocket
ever built its biggest customer NASA is
paying SpaceX billions to have Starship
land astronauts back on the moon for the
Artemis program it's only the beginning
it's a development program but they are
meeting their Milestones how closely are
you watching these flights well NASA is
all over them uh when it comes to
putting NASA astronauts on these
machines but at this stage for SpaceX
failure is an option
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman Atlanta
I'm gonna remember that phrase guys
classic successful next time I burn
dinner yes
yeah I think that's thinking the same
thing Sony or next time there's this
group of any kind I'm going to be using
that lesson learned